Joey I'm hearing you know how does
Barbara feeling man a little something
like that I've been cutting here for 29
years my list of clients don't have
service at over celebrities are the
boots mr. Jay Pharoah
he's a Tracy Morgan today we get my man
Joey that James Harden got some pictures
here Joey
the evolution of James Harden's build up
to his iconic stop Wow
should we got like 2007 here little
James are in high school like he's
pouring like a number two and that was
like the style like around 2007 people
are starting to cut their brave look
2009 okay well the beer the year the
beard is growing their smile look like
the money coming the chipped tooth
that's not gonna be there after that
first check you know what and is
interesting because like even like in
2009 like people wasn't even like trying
to grow their beard I even have him that
type of style okay Joey this is the
beginning of the Mohawk as you can tell
it's faded on the side his barbers
allowing that you glow and it back on
top this is James Hart none knew like
when I first discovered him he had the
Mohawk he was like kind of standout at
this point
2014 you go who's coming the beard is
like growing it to his highest point
this crazy I never noticed after in 2011
always thought his beard was at the same
length but going through these photos
he's like he was actually growing and
growing growing at the top like is kind
of small kind of like wet and a little
skinny you know top but that's cool
that's pretty much like the pump bucket
the most they went in skinnier to show
that full effect Lana stop 2017 James
Harden has met his tear grow out as you
can see the Mohawk itself is wider it's
not the clothes sheet just a football
2019 yeah I think this is probably my
favorite lick out of all of them
it's like a little lower on the side and
just the way it goes in it's just like
it grows in smoke and also it just fix
all the objects on the face arborist our
nose forehead the contour shakes then he
has that his mama blessed me with so it
looks great if I go to another Barbara
what would I call this little specific
so you want to tell them to give you
like pretty much like a burst fate and
leave your beer to its highest point so
basically you starting from my take care
point and it just exploding like right
there we go
so from here one ollie up to go to is
popping exploding so that's a burst feed
let me ask you this what is the easiest
way to communicate with the barber
pictures are great Joe you know make
sure your phone is charged when you go
into the barber shop so you can show the
barber hey this is what I want between
New York City and Philadelphia they say
you know let me get a Caesar and
Philadelphia to me the dark feed it's
the same exact haircut it's just
different terminology so basically I'm
leaving the slang along and just showing
the budget can't go wrong with that why
you decide to grow your beard Joey
because you know what when you don't
have a beer when I had the five o'clock
shadow
like nobody really no one no one paid
you don't mind but once I had the beer
things I hope he sees this is this is
rude I get that so the the problem that
I'm having right now I'm starting to
notice
but one side that part of me was dating
a little bit so I just have to like
spread you're not trying to cover it up
so what you here today Joey maybe have
the disease like a little bit of lesion
just to show you a template of how we
can get that line back out to look
natural it doesn't look like this
procedure about the 50 calibers first
order of operation here I'm going to
remove the weight I'll take my 50
caliber McComb removing the weight is
removing the thickness opening the hakka
to the feed the next order operation
here we want to fade this down to a nice
length okay be like well like a 1 and
I'm going downwards and for himself so
this is called feeding it down thirdly I
want to get that bling like that burst
fie type feeling right here so we could
knock all the dark spots out
so James Harden's Mohawk is cool right
here so I'm not gonna touch nothing
right here at all because I wanted to
grow
why didn't explore the operation and I
really liked gonna get some shears
thinning shears so I want to just take
just go like the first line and just
trim just split ends on the hook once I
got my right side done
this is gonna be my template for my left
side so now on my left side
st. order operation here got my Bush
clone I'm a 50 caliber clipper so let me
ask you something
well what inspired you to be a barber
got me into barbering is late 80s early
90s there was a lot of you know gun
violence and a lot of drugs you know
negativity going on and the barber shop
was a safe haven for a lot of us they
taught us how to be you know good young
men handle yourself in the streets my
barber shop I played that role you know
a mentor a big brother you know what
father figure someone for somebody else
to look up to in real time what I mean
by real time every single day so my next
step here I just want to add some
moisture to his hair I got something
special be right back I'll call this one
here my portable shampoo boy see the
fine mist to shoot out so I need some
dampness here on the circular motion so
I got a water and astringent mixed in
one to clean his scalp and open up his
pores I need to add some product to his
hair so that's um locked and twist you
you don't even need that much it's like
a fingertip
well I can get it all up in there the
lock and twist gel helps give it body
oh we looking good now I got my blow
dryer
so what I have here is just 30
especially caliber to get a nice crisp
shape up
so Joey is spinning out right here so I
went over to grab some natural hair
fibers and I'm going to just put the
card right here get some misty misty
beard so after the water and the
stringent combination I want to grab
some beard oil no need a lot just a few
drops to put on the beer get that shiny
coat like a brand new painted car you
want to massage it into the hair to the
surface of the Dee cheek swab my oil
wanna grab my blow dryer and a comb
attachment so let me ask you this why
are you adding oil after you wet my hair
the main reason is after the water or
shampoo and astringent combination your
pores are open so I apply the oil to the
follicle and massage it into the solder
face so it gets down to the cheek and
why is he so important and dry and
happened it's definitely important to
add heat to the oil so you can make it
silky smooth
so we got the further raise of Julie
that is pretty much to still then give
you a natural fresh arch shape up that's
pretty clean I'm talking about do it
so Joey has some new growth going on
here and I kind of like when I highlight
that
I'm gonna fill it in with some natural
fibers doing this enough time trains the
line and keep the line out to its
furthest capacity the last step is what
I truly truly like is sculpting so you
know I grab my favorite racquet that I
like it's plastic
easy to maintain and take care of and
the sanitary so twisting in a circular
motion is locking the Mohawk it also has
a pick that you can pick the hair out so
Joey I think I'm done jewelry you know I
got the shade is James Harden then I
work very hard but first I give you some
tips to maintain you we all know that
enhancements and the fibers you know
aren't real they're just there as an
illusion you can do it yourself it's
very very easy to do and get you a nice
no curl bracket to curl your hair that
and maybe you if you want you can tie it
down tonight
so it doesn't get my stuff alright let's
see
Oh oh wow Wow this is it wow this is yo
this is it when we talking about
greatness right now I'm stepping out
tonight for sure like for real my hey
man you doesn't save my life man
appreciate you brought this you're the
most likely man come from killing their
brotherly love me you know show me a lot
of love out here man I'm feeling good so
we do
you